PLEDGE ARENA.
ARSSON, McAVOY, PA
WAITIT PASTRNAK IS THE
ONE THEY WANT TO GET T HE
SCORES. RIGHTLCYK HOLDING ON TO.
GUARDED BY GOURDE, HERE'S
MARCHAND, HE'LL DUST THEY CONTI
FEEDING THE PUCK ON THE POWER
PLAY.
THEY WANT HIM TO SHOOT THE PUCK.
HE
REBOUND, COYLE ISLLY T
SHOTS ARE 11-7.
THEY FAVOR BOSTON. WITH THE
POKE CHECK LOOK THERE.
I LIKE THAT. IT IN HOUNDED
BY  NO.
>> J.T.: GRUBAUER STANDING
STRO
CHECKED BY BLACKWELL.
MARCHAND THIS WAY, SHEAHAN'S ST.
JUST GET ENOUGH OF THE TOE DeBR.
LOOKS LIKE HE'FIRST.
>> John: LAUZON TRIED TO BAT IT.
HE'LL CUT THROUGH CENTER.
56 SECONDS LEFT IN THEE
A ONE TIMER, BANGED HOME BY A O
TIMER SPLIT HERE.
GRUBAUER HAS TO STAY ALL THE WAY
AT THE
REILLY FOR BRAD MARCHAND, HE'LL
BE.T IN.
BRAD MARCHAND WITH A
JORDAN EBERLE, CAN DO
THERE.
EBERLE JUST HAS TOO MUCH TIME,
TOO MUCH SPACE.
HE'S ABLE TO PULL AND SEATTLE
IS OUT.
RYAN DONATO, PASS
FORMER BRUIN GETS IT IN CONTROL.
THE BRUINS GET IT OUT.
KRAKEN PICK IT STRONG, THE
TURNOVER RIGHT OUT IN THE
BLACK WELL FOR APPLETON, KICKS
PUCKS ARE BOUNCING IN FRONT.
FREDERIC, CENTER, HERE COMES
JARNKROK, SIX SE
ON